has now been confirmed that monday the
19th of september is going to be the day
that the state funeral will happen at
westminster abbey it'll happen at 11 a.m
in the morning and earlier on today we
were told that the king had authorized
that that will be a national day of
mourning it will be a bank holiday
now also it's been confirmed today that
at the moment the queen is currently uh
in the ballroom her coffin is in the
ballroom uh at balmoral where
members of the estate there are able to
pay tribute
but tomorrow the coffin will be moved so
at
10 a.m in the morning
gamekeepers will carry her coffin out of
balmoral castle where she passed away
earlier this week they will slowly drive
from balmoral to edinburgh the slow
drive will allow people to line the
streets to pay their respects
and the coffin is due to arrive in
edinburgh at around 3 30 in the
afternoon where it will be taken to the
palace of hollywood house where
overnight again the coffin will be in
residence to allow royal household staff
to pay their respects
if we then look towards monday now this
is a day where we can anticipate that we
will see
the king delivering a speech here in
london in westminster hall in front of
the house of lords and the house of
commons before he then travels up to
edinburgh where of course the queen's
coffin remains and a service will be
carried out at st jars cathedral a
service of remembrance which will see
members of all family involved but also
people from every aspect of scottish
society
the queen's coffin will then stay at st
jars cathedral where members of the
public will then be allowed to
pay their own respects they will be able
to enter the cathedral to see her coffin
we'll also see members of the family
staging a vigil
around that coffin on monday evening
now on tuesday the queen's coffin will
start to make its journey
down to london
we understand that in the evening of
tuesday the 13th
it will be flown from edinburgh to
northholt and then transferred by road
to buckingham palace where the coffin
will be met by members of the royal
family
and then on wednesday a moment that we
were anticipating the queen's coffin
will then be taken in a procession
from buckingham palace to the palace of
westminster
and it will then lie in state in
westminster hall
so that
people can pay their respects
and over the coming four days they are
anticipating
that tens of thousands of people are
likely to line the route
queuing up to
pay their final respects
as they walk through westminster hall
now running concurrently to those plans
when it comes to the queen's coffin the
king also has his own plans now we
understand that tomorrow he is due to
meet up with the secretary general of
the commonwealth and also host high
commissioners as well then on monday as
i said earlier he will address
the palace of westminster the houses of
house of commons and the house of lords
and then make that journey up to
edinburgh for that service
at st giles cathedral on tuesday he will
then travel to belfast to hillsborough
castle he will meet the secretary of
state of northern ireland and other
leaders of political parties and there
will be messages of condolence at the
northern ireland assembly we're also
told that on friday the 16th uh he will
travel to wales and then of course as
it's now been confirmed the date of
queen elizabeth ii's state funeral is
monday the 19th of september
yesterday so the dates now
the events over the coming days now
clearly set out by buckingham palace
just before you go are there any
more details about the funeral itself
we've been told that we can anticipate
every day
more details in terms of how
everything is going to look so which
members of the royal family are likely
to take part for example in a procession
that will see the coffin move from
hollywood house in edinburgh to
saint-gel's cathedral which members of
the family will take part in the
procession when it comes to the coffin
again moving from buckingham palace to
the palace of westminster
and i think there's going to have been
an awful awful lot of detail put into
that state funeral we are told that the
queen can was consulted on all of her
funeral plans
and so we have to we have to wait
in essence
for a few days before they will give us
more details on
the look the feel of that funeral but i
think we can anticipate that leaders
around the world are likely to want to
to travel over here
for that moment to pay their respects
when you consider the tributes that
we've heard from right around the world
already
listening to the briefing from those who
have been involved in informing these
plans at the earl marshall the duke of
norfolk was talking about the great
honour that it will be to deliver the
plans
along the lines of the queen's wishes
how the the whole royal household is
joining the world in in feeling that
sense of grief at the moment but they
are a team that are committed to doing
justice to making sure that this is the
funeral
that such a remarkable woman deserved
also when it comes to king john
king charles iii
we tell that he is of course going to be
carrying out all of the necessary state
duties that have been passed to him
but it was made very clear that his main
focus at the moment and i think we've
already seen this in his address to the
nation the words he delivered today at
the accession council the fact that
yesterday he wanted to get out to meet
the crowds his main focus is now on
leading the royal family the nation
and realms in this moment of mourning